thousands of people are still missing
and fear dead
[Music]
buried under the mud and Rubble or swept
out to sea
search and rescue a force continue but
the chances of finding people trapped
and Alive are increasingly sleep the
communities in eastern Libya today are
surrounded by deaths and destruction
bodies are littering the streets washing
back up on shore and buried under
collapsed buildings and debris in just
two hours one of my colleagues counted
over 200 buddies on the beach near the
road
the wall of water carried many people
out to sea their bodies lie on beaches
having been washed ashore
bodies need to be documented and buried
in labeled body bags Graves need to be
met so that there is record of who is
buried there
the efforts make it possible for loved
one to later recover a body and have the
closure of a private barrier they help
to prevent people from going missing
forever
there is Mountain fear of disease as the
hidden body is decomposed
My Wish now I want my brother and his
family back my home is damaged the most
precious thing for us I want my brother
and his family I want to find them and
bury them they are under the rubble
people went in the water others under
the rubble they can bring machines and
pull them out I can take them to the
buildings to see rotting bodies there
are families there that I know and I
know where they are they are starting to
smell libyans here from the west of the
country have driven across front lines
determined to help those in need in this
politically divided nation but just
getting the air to where it's needed
most remains a huge challenge
it's not easy for a man to go through
this only God knows what we're going
through
we're back to square one no one helps
you even the government didn't help us
we are left on our own in the streets
the government doesn't even have the
resources to help thankfully we libyans
are as one those from Tripoli miserata
and the South all came to help
foreign aid continues to arrive by air
but Darna needs more International
assistance and fast
survivors struggle to comprehend this
catastrophe clearing the mud and debris
from what remains of their homes and
waiting for help
resource Al Jazeera Tripoli
and also Zero's Malik trainer is also
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera